speaking about full house a couple of
questions okay why do you think the olon
twins didn't do the Fuller house sequel
why did why did they turn that down did
you ever talk to them about it sort of
it was a messy time for for that show
because I mean I I was upset at first
and it kind of got out and I was only
upset because I just you know I just
thought it would be nice to have him for
a minute I produced it we came up with
the idea and everything so it got weird
in the in the press and stuff but they
just they just didn't want to you know
they weren't they weren't acting and I
don't think a real offer came through
and Lori Lin said to me she goes you
know they just won two cfda Awards
that's like winning Oscars I don't want
to come do this I said okay I get it I
get it they came to Bob's funeral and it
it was yeah and it they were so it was
so beautiful and it was we all needed it
cuz we did they speak no but what they
did Howard was they got us all together
and said we love you we loved our
childhood we're grateful for you guys we
we thank you for making those 8 years so
beautiful for us we have such fond
memories we love you love you and
everybody just needed to hear that it
was a really I think it was Bob doing it
you
know